aland you mentioned you've written
dozens of screenplays and you've watched
many projects gather steam and then they
not go through or still lies sleeping
somewhere so what did you do differently
this time around while Bob's new suit
you got the call from hunter you knew
you had to move on this what was
different this time what was different
this time is that everything was done in
a context of how much would it cost
where would we shoot it what could be
done it was very pragmatic all the way
through it's different from being say at
Fox and riding a massive historical epic
for Nicole Kidman which I did in which
literally the sky's the limit you can
write anything you want and so it was a
different mode of creativity with Bob's
new suit so why do you think that that
was different just because you knew
there were parameters I knew that it had
to be limited that I you know it was
also it's a huge production I mean it's
it's was much bigger than any of us
realized it was the second day of
shooting it was oh my god this is so big
I mean it and it was hardly although it
is a small indie it certainly wasn't in
terms of production or in size of cast
and a number of costumes and locations
and but how much is it going to cost how
much is it going to cost how much time
do we have how much time do we have can
we really do all these pages in a day
can we really get this shot let's cut
that scene let's cut this scene in half
that's very different from the resources
of a studio that wants to make a
tentpole movie with the major film star
so your advice to another filmmaker who
maybe have had several things fizzle out
and pass or gotten close what would you
tell them to really push it maybe
they've said you know this time I really
want to do it it's almost like a
relationship you get close it doesn't
work you back off or buying a house you
get close and we pull out of escrow so
what do you tell a filmmaker that maybe
he's going through the same thing I will
tell I'm going to tell a story through
bookworm I met Susan Sontag and I was
having dinner with michael silverblatt
and Susan Sontag and at that time I had
about 25 films fall apart and she said
hasn't this broken your heart and I it
shocked me because she was right it had
broken my heart she said you must go
home and immediately start something
that only you love but only you want to
see and I did i'm going to revisit that
same screenplay now because i couldn't
get it financed that I almost did but it
changed my career it changed my writing
which is what I needed to do i returned
to watching the movies that I that had
drawn me into the world of movies going
back to the source beginning again and I
think that that and I still do that you
know I still do that I watched rules of
the game again which is a genre noir
film it's probably among my two or three
favorite films I've seen it several
dozen times I watched it again in
January because i needed that
stimulation of returning to what it is
that i really love and care about
because only that I think what give you
the energy to move forward do you think
those prior 25 other
x or so weren't really we were what you
cared about oh I think they were they
were but I had I had run aground I had
you know when you had lead a creative
life you lose your way from time to time
it happens to everyone and that was the
sonntag conversation reawakened me at a
critical time in my life
you